okay can I get rid of this shoe now I
actually have to use this whiteboard I
know believe it or not that was just
there to give you a visual cue we're
going to be talking about there we go
we're going to be talking about a
converse today sadly it's not a converse
true that you are totally welcome if you
can find a way to like make this about
shoes I'm just gonna leave that there as
a visual cue for you we're talking about
the converse of what's the what's the
name of the topic that were in at the
moment
it's called pipe ounces theorem now
we're going to look at what we call the
converse of Pythagoras theorem and you
might think what does that mean is it a
shoe made out of right-angled triangles
well if Congress ever put out such a
shoe I would absolutely buy it but we
actually mean converse in a different
way and I'm gonna explain what that is
shortly
so first let's remember what
Pythagoras's theorem actually says okay
it's to do with a certain kind of shape
then remember triangles can we be more
specific than that because it's not just
any triangle right yeah writing with
triangles thank you very much so a
triangle which has a right angle in it
so Pythagoras theorem in a very
condensed way says if you have a
right-angled triangle I'm just going to
draw a little right-angled triangle here
okay if you have a right-angled triangle
and you have a look at its three sides
in order of size or you can look at this
longest side in a right angle triangle
what's it called again that's it yeah
the hypotenuse thank you very much now
how Putin uses the longest side it's
opposite the right angle if you have a
right angle triangle then we can write
this on this equation the theorem when
we used algebra to do this can anyone
actually I'm not going to say can anyone
can we all quote what Pythagoras's
theorem is we might start with the a
since that's alphabetical can we
statement count of three let's see if we
do it one two three a squared plus B
squared equals C squared we know that
well done or you mouths that
successfully nothing I couldn't tell so
good job this is Pythagoras theorem and
it's kind of a short form of saying the
long wordy version do you remember that
you'd have to write this down but it's
the sum of the squares on the two
shorter sides equals the square on the
longer side but that's like 25 whole
words right
whereas I can just use a few characters
and say the same thing okay so this is
Pythagoras theorem now we've already
actually used this before we just
haven't put the language on it so think
back to some of the lessons you've had
from mrs. Lee's recently the converse of
Pythagoras's theorem is to say this kind
of in Reverse right see how you've got
if you know about the triangle then you
can say something about the sides the
converse I'm gonna get my black e the
converse is to say the same kind of
sentence but in reverse order almost
right which is why converse and reversal
sounds similar if I look at a triangle
any triangle that you like right and I
square the two shorter sides and add
them up right if I check that against
the square on the longest side of the
triangle for any triangle right and if
they happen to be equal if this is the
case right remember I'm just meeting any
triangle you like doesn't have to have
any right angles or anything like that
if you measure this and it happens to be
the case then you can say oh this must
be a right-angled triangle this guy here
is going to draw it it has to be the
case and so we looked at Pythagorean
triads do you remember what's the the
smallest set of three numbers that you
guys have counted over and over again
that gives you the nice three sides yeah
three four and five it happens all the
time sometimes you get like kind of
counterfeit version two three four five
like six eight ten six eight ten sounds
different but why is it actually the
same one why it's actually the same yeah
I've just doubled three four and five so
it's kind of like there's this triangle
which might be three four five and then
there's just like it's bigger cousin
right where everything is twice the size
okay so this is what the converse is now
on your little table there you can see
I've given you a bit of space on the
left hand side is where we can write
basically this right a right angle
triangle this is in the top left hand
corner regular old the original
Pythagoras's theorem means you've got a
right angle triangle and then it leads
to this relationship a squared plus B
squared equals C squared
and underneath that I've got a spot
there for the
verse right if I actually want to say
this the other way around if I want to
measure the sides first because I don't
know where this triangle is right angled
or not then I can actually say I can
conclude if this is true okay
now we've sort of left you to your own
devices have you've gone through this
sort of investigative booklet to try and
work out some of these problems but
right now what I want to show you is
kind of the right they're like gold
standard way to set this out so I'm
going to ask you to draw get a ruler out
I'm gonna ask you to draw a triangle for
me like so so it doesn't have to be huge
maybe sort of mm four to five
centimeters across big enough that you
can see where the sides are in relation
to each other
so here's a triangle and what we want to
do is show prove that it's right-angled
and what we're going to use is the
converse of Pythagoras's theorem to do
that right so how will we go about this
I'm going to show you like I mentioned
the gold standard way and it's a bit
long and detailed right some of you
might think wow do I have to put this
much working into every time I think
about a right-angled triangle I'm going
to encourage you as much as possible to
put as much detail as you can because
the more detailed you are the clearer
you've communicated something right when
we're concise that's nice if we want to
be quick but sometimes you lose detail
right if you know someone's to ask me a
question I just say yeah sure if you
don't know what the original question
was you don't know what my answer means
you don't know what I'm agreeing to and
so just having a really brief answer
doesn't give you as much detail so
here's how I'm going to suggest we go
about this could you raise your hand if
you draw on the triangle and it's
numbers by now heads up we pretty much
all there okay great think your hands
down so if you've drawn the triangle
here's the first thing I'm going to
encourage you to do we've got this
triangle but these sides I don't know
what their names are they don't have any
names at all okay so in order to be able
to talk about the sides of this triangle
I'm actually going to provide some names
I'm gonna call this particular triangle
a
b/c by the way little note maybe you
remember seeing this from last year when
we described the corners of a shape or a
triangle we tend to use capital letters
when we describe the sides we tend to
use little letters you don't have to but
it's just sort of it's nice to be
consistent and be able to use the same
things across other people's
communication so now that I've done this
I'm gonna say in this triangle and
because I've given it actual you know
corners with names I can call this
triangle a b c in this triangle i'm now
going to think about it from this point
of view i'm gonna look at Pythagoras's
theorem and see if i can make it work
for this particular triangle so i'm
gonna say okay which are the two shorter
sides a and b in this case a b is one of
the shorter sides and what's the other
shorter side yeah go ahead
bc very good so I'm gonna say a B that's
when the sides I'm interested in I'm
gonna square it in a second and then the
other one is like you told me base say
that also needs to be squared to check
out where the Pythagoras theorem is
going to work out okay so now that I've
described where I'm looking in the
triangle I'm now going to do what we
call evaluate I'm gonna look at the
numbers the values of those sides right
in this case I've got a 5 squared and a
12 squared now some of you might
instinctively reach for your calculator
at this point and I have we have no
problems in calculators right now but
for numbers like this I encourage you to
use your brain rather than immediately
jump into your calculator because I
think we can work this out John talking
about 5 squared is 25 very good and you
can tell me what 12 squared is yeah go
ahead yeah
144 thank you very much now if you
couldn't do those in your head no
problems but it's helpful if you try and
practice to do this because your brain
is just like any other muscle in your
body get struggle with use ok question
ok so you are now already adding these
up together it's a hundred and
sixty-nine ok so at this point I've
worked it all that I know what these two
shorter sides add up to when they're
squared now I'm going to look at the
longer side what's the name of the
longer side and yeah at the back they
say thank you much so that's the name
of the longest side I'm gonna square it
and now I'm going to what was it called
again when we look at the numbers the
values we evaluate that's literally what
it means put the values in that's 13
does anyone know what 13 squared is sir
hurrah five twelve thirteen it does end
up satisfying it's one of those
Pythagorean triads so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to say since these two
squared equal to this squared because
you can see the numbers matching up I'm
even going to write it like so since
that is true triangle ABC is
right-angled okay so this is the gold
standard it's kind of lengthy right but
it's completely beyond a shadow of a
doubt a proof that's really clear anyone
could pick this up and by reading your
diagram and your words and your careful
working out they can know exactly what
you are thinking okay